the normal distribution is arguably the
most important concept in statistics
everything we do or almost everything we
do in inferential statistics which is
essentially making inferences based on
data points
is to some degree based on the normal
distribution and so what i want to do in
this video and in this in this uh in
this
spreadsheet is to essentially give you
as deep an understanding of the normal
distribution as possible and you know
just in the rest of your life you're
always if someone says oh we're assuming
a normal distribution you're like oh i
know what that is this is the formula
and i understand how to use it et cetera
et cetera so this spreadsheet just so
you know is downloadable at
www.khanacademy.org
downloads slash and if you just type
that part in you'll see everything
that's downloadable but then download
slash normal intro dot xls and then
you'll get this spreadsheet right here
and i think it's i did this in the right
standard anyway if you go on to
wikipedia and if you were to type in
normal distribution or you were to do a
search for a normal distribution let me
actually get my
pen tool going
this is what you would see i literally
copied and pasted this right here from
wikipedia and i know it looks daunting
you know you have all these greek
letters there but this is just
the sigma right here that is just the
standard deviation of the distribution
we'll play with that a little bit with
in this in this chart and see what that
means
and well i mean you know what the
standard deviation is in general but
this is the standard deviation of this
distribution which is a probability
density function and i encourage you to
re-watch the video on probability
density functions because it's a little
bit of a transition going from the
binomial distribution which is discrete
right and the binomial distribution say
oh what is the probability of getting a
5 and you just kind of look at that
histogram or that bar chart you say oh
that's the probability but in a
continuous
probability distribution or a continuous
probability density function you can't
just say what is the probability of me
getting a 5 you have to say what is the
probability of me getting between let's
say a 4.5
and a 5.5 you have to give it
some range and then your probability
isn't given by just reading this graph
the probability is given by the area
under that curve
right
it would be given by this area and for
those of y'all who know calculus
if p of x is our probability density
function it doesn't have to be a normal
distribution although it almost always
well it often is a normal distribution
the way you actually figure out the
probability
of of you know this let's say between
four and a half and five and a half what
is the probability you know this is
whatever the the odds of me getting
between four and a half and five and a
half inches of rain tomorrow it'll
actually be
the integral
from four and a half
to five and a half
of this probability density function or
this probability density function
dx right so that's just the area of the
curve for those of you who don't know
calculus yet i encourage you to watch
that playlist but all this is is saying
the area in the curve from here to here
and actually turns out for the normal
distribution this isn't an easy thing to
evaluate analytically and so you do it
numerically and that kind of you know
you don't have to feel bad about doing
it numerically because like oh how do i
take the integral of this
there's actually functions for it and
you can even approximate i mean one way
you could approximate it is you could
use it the way you approximate integrals
in general where you could say well what
is the area of this what's roughly you
know the area of this trapezoid so you
could figure out the area of that
trapezoid taking the average of that
point and that point and multiplying it
by the base or you could just take the
level the let me change colors because i
think i'm overdoing it with the green
or you could just take
the
height of this line right here and
multiply it by the base and you'll get
the area of this rectangle
which might be a pretty good
approximation for the area under the
curve right because you'll have a little
bit extra over here but you're going to
miss a little bit over there so it might
be a pretty good approximation that's
actually what i do in the other video
just to approximate the area under the
curve and give you a good sense that the
normal distribution is what the binomial
distribution becomes essentially if you
have a many many many many trials and
what's interesting about the normal
distribution just so you know i don't
know if i mentioned this already this
right here
this is the graph
and
and this is you know just another word
you know people might talk about the
central limit theorem but this is really
kind of one of the most
important or interesting things about
our universe central limit
i won't prove it here but it essentially
tells us you could kind of understand it
by looking at the other video where we
talk about flipping coins and if we were
to do many many many flips of coins
right those are independent trials of
each other and if you take the sum of
all of your flips if you were to give
yourself one point if you got a head
every time and if you take the sum of
them as you approach an infinite number
of flips you approach the normal
distribution
and what's interesting about that
is each of those trials in the case of
flipping a coin each trial is a flip of
the coin each of those trials don't have
to have a normal distribution so we
could be talking about molecular
interactions and you know every time
compound x interacts with compound y
you know what might a result doesn't
have to have be normally distributed but
what happens is if you take a sum of a
ton of those interactions then all of a
sudden the end result will be normally
distributed and this is why this is such
an important distribution it shows up in
nature all of the time and if people are
trying to kind of if you do take data
points from something that is very very
complex and that it is the sum of
arguably many many almost infinite
individual independent trials it's a
pretty good assumption to assume the
normal distribution we'll talk we'll do
other videos where we talk about when it
is a good assumption when it isn't a
good assumption
but anyway just to digest this a little
bit and let me
let me actually rewrite it this is what
you'll see on wikipedia but this could
be rewritten as
over
sigma times the square root of 2 pi
times x is just e to that power so it's
just e to the this whole thing over here
minus
x minus
the mean
squared
over
sigma squared this is the standard
deviation standard deviation squared is
just the variance right and just so you
know how you use this you're like oh wow
there are so many greek letters here
what do i do
this tells you the height of the normal
distribution function that you know
let's say that this is the distribution
of um i don't know of of of people's um
i don't know how how how far north they
live from my house or something i don't
know i'm well no that's not a good one
let's say it's it's people's heights
above five nine let's say that this was
five nine and not zero
right
what this tells you is
if you say how you know what problem
what percentage of people or i guess
what is the probability if you want to
figure out what is the probability of
some finding someone who is roughly five
inches taller than the average right
here what you would do is you would put
in this number here you know this 5 into
x
and then you know the standard deviation
because you've taken a bunch of samples
you know the variance which is the
standard deviation squared you know the
mean and you just put your x in there
it'll tell you the height of the
function and then you have to give it a
range you have to you can't just say how
many people are exactly five inches
taller than average you would actually
say how many people are between 5.1
inches and 4.9 inches taller than the
average you have to give it a little bit
of range because no one is exactly or
you know it's almost infinitely
impossible to the atom to be exactly
five foot nine even the definition of an
inch isn't defined that particularly so
that's how you use this function i think
it's
you know this is so heavily used in you
know one it shows up in nature but in
all of inferential statistics i think it
it behooves you to become as familiar
with this formula as possible and i
guess to make that happen
let me play around a little bit with
this formula just to kind of give you an
intuition of how everything works out
etcetera etcetera so if i were to take
this and you know i'd i'd like to just
maybe help you memorize it this could be
rewritten as if we take the sigma into
the square root sign if we take the
standard deviation in there it becomes
1 over the square root of 2 pi
sigma squared i've never seen it written
this way but it gives me a little
intuition that sigma squared it's always
written as you know sigma squared but
it's really just the variance and the
variance is what you calculate before
you calculate the standard deviation so
that's interesting and then this top
right here this could be written as
e
to the minus one half
times and if we were to just take this
if we were you know both of these things
here are squared so we could just say x
minus the mean
over sigma
squared and this kind of clarifies a
little bit what's going on here a little
bit better because what's this
x minus sigma is the distance between
whatever point we want to find
let's say we're here x minus
x minus mu
x minus mu mu is the mean so that's here
so that's this distance
and then this is the standard deviation
which is this distance
so this right this
in here tells me how many standard
deviations i am away from the mean and
that's actually called the standard
z-score i talked about in the other
video and then we square that and then
we take this to the minus one-half well
let me rewrite that if i were to write
e to the minus one half times a
that's the same thing as e to the a
to the minus one half power right
if you take something to an exponent
then take that to an exponent you can
just multiply these exponents
so likewise this could be rewritten as
this is equal to 1 over
the square root of 2
pi
sigma squared which is just the variance
and i'm just playing around with the
form because i really want you to see
all the ways that you know maybe you'll
get a little intuition and i encourage
you to email me if you see some insight
on you know
why this exists in all of that but once
again i think it is cool that all of a
sudden we have this other formula that
has pi and e in it and this is really
just you know this is what the central
you know so many phenomenon this is uh
are described by this and once again pi
and e show up together right just like e
to the i pi is equal to negative one
tells you something about about about
our universe
but anyway i could rewrite this as e
to the
x minus
mu over
sigma squared and all of that to the
minus one half
summing the minus one half power that's
just one over the square root which is
already going on here so we could just
rewrite this
over here as
one over
the square root
of two
pi times the variance
times e
to essentially our z score squared right
if we say z is this thing in here
z is how many standard deviations we are
from the mean
z score squared and all of a sudden this
kind of becomes a very clean
you know we just say 2 pi times our
variance times e to the number of
standard deviations we are away from the
mean you square that you take the square
root of that thing
and invert it and that's also that's
that's the normal distribution so anyway
i wanted to do that just i thought it
was neat and it's interesting to play
around with it and that way if you see
it in any of these other forms in the
rest of your life you won't say what's
that i thought the normal distribution
was this or was this and now you know
with that said let's play around a
little bit with this normal distribution
so this spreadsheet
i've plotted normal distribution you can
change the assumptions that are in this
kind of a
green blue color so right now it's
plotting it with a mean of zero and a
standard deviation of four and i just
write the variance here just for your
information the variance is just the
standard deviation squared and so what
happens when you change the mean
so if the mean goes from zero to let's
say it goes to 5.
notice this graph just shifted to the
right by 5 right it was centered here
now it's centered over here if we make
it
minus 5 what happens the whole bell
curve just shifts
5 to the left from the center now what
happens when you change the standard
deviation right the standard deviation
is a measure of
you know the variance is the average
squared distance from the mean the
standard deviation is the square root of
that so it's kind of not exactly but
kind of the average distance from the
mean so the smaller the standard
deviation the closer a lot of the points
are going to be to the mean so we should
get kind of a a narrower graph and let's
see that that happens so when the
standard deviation is 2
we see that
the graph you're more likely to be
really close to the mean than further
away and if you make the standard
deviation
i don't know if you make it 10
all of a sudden you get a really flat
graph and this thing keeps going on
forever and that's another that's a key
difference the binomial distribution is
always finite you can only have a finite
number of values while the normal
distribution is defined over the entire
real number line so
you know the probability if you have an
x if you have a mean of minus 5 and a
standard deviation of 10 the probability
of having like you know getting a
thousand here
is very very low but there is some some
probability it's like you know
there's some probability that i fall
that all of the atoms in my body just
arrange perfectly that i fall through
the seed i'm sitting on it's very
unlikely and it probably won't happen in
the life of the universe but it can
happen and you know and that could be
described by a normal distribution
because it says you know anything can
happen although it could be very very
very unprobable
so you know the the thing i talked about
at the beginning of the video is when
you figure out a normal distribution you
have to
you can't just look at this point on the
graph let me get the drop pen tool back
you have to figure out the area of the
curve under the curve between two points
right so if i wanted to say let's say
this was our distribution i said what is
the probability that i get 0 i don't
know what phenomenon this is describing
but that 0 happened
if i say exactly 0 the probability is
zero
because i shouldn't do zero too much
because the area under the curve just
under zero it's not a there's no area
it's just a line you have to say between
a range so you have to say the
probability between
um you know let's say
minus
and actually i can type it in here on
our
on our
i can say the probability between
let's say minus 0.005
and plus 0.05
is well it rounded so it says they're
close to zero let me do it between minus
one
and between one
right it calculated at seven percent and
i'll show you how i calculated this in a
second
so let me get the screen draw tool so
what did i just do this between -1 and 1
and i'll show you the behind the scenes
what excel is doing we're going from -1
which is roughly right here
to 1
and we're calculating the area under the
curve
right we're calculating this area
or for those of you who know calculus
we're calculating
the integral
from -1 to 1
of this function where the standard
deviation is right here is 10
and the mean
is minus 5. and actually let me put that
in so we're calculating for this example
the way it's drawn right here
the
normal distribution function let's see
our standard deviation is 10
times the square root of 2 pi
times e
to the minus one half
times
x
minus our mean our mean is negative
right now right our mean is minus five
so it's x plus five
over the standard deviation squared
which is
the variance so that's a hundred
squared dx
this is what this number is right here
this seven percent or actually .07 is
the area right under there now
unfortunately for us in the world this
isn't an easy integral to evaluate
analytically even for those of us who
know our calculus so this tends to be
done numerically and and kind of an easy
way to do this and uh well not an easy
way but
a function has been defined called the
cumulative distribution function that is
a useful tool for figuring out this area
so what the cumulative distribution
function is
is essentially let me call it
the cumulative distribution function
it tell you know it's a function of x
it gives us the area under the curve
under this curve so let's say that this
is x right here
that's our x it tells you the area under
the curve up to x or so another way to
think about it it tells you what is the
probability that you land at some value
less than your x value so it's the it's
the area from minus infinity
to x
of our probability density function
dx
and there's actually a an excel when you
actually use the excel
normal distribution function the you
know the you say norm
distribution
you have to give it your x value
you give it the mean you give it the
standard deviation and then you say
whether you want the you want you want
the cumulative distribution in which
case you say true or you want just this
normal distribution which you say fall
so if you wanted to graph this
right here you would say false
in caps
if you wanted to graph the cumulative
distribution function which i do down
here
let me move this down a little bit
let me get out of the pen tool
so the cumulative distribution function
is
right over here
then you say true when you make that
excel call so this is a cumulative
distribution function for the same
for this this is a normal distribution
here's a cumulative distribution and
just so you get the intuition is if you
want to know what is the probability
that i get a value less than 20 right so
i can get any value less than 20 given
this distribution
the cumulative distribution right here
let me get make it so you can see the
if you go to 20
you just go right to that point there
and you say wow the probability of
getting 20 or less it's pretty high you
know it's approaching 100 that makes
sense because most of the area under
this curve
is less than 20. or if you said what's
the probability of getting less than 5
less than minus 5 well minus 5 was the
mean so half of your results should be
above that and half should be below and
if you go to this point right here you
can see that this right here is fifty
percent so the probability of getting
less than
minus five is exactly fifty percent
so what you do is if i wanted to know
if i want to know the probability of
going getting between negative 1 and 1
what i do is let me get back to my pen
tool
what i do is i figure out what is the
probability of getting
minus one or lower right
so i figure out this whole area
and then i figure out the probability of
getting one or lower which is this whole
area well let me do it in a different
color one or lower
is
everything there and i subtract the
yellow area from the magenta area and
i'll just get what's ever left over here
right so what i do is i take that's
exactly what i did in the spreadsheet
let me scroll down
this might be taxing my computer by
taking the screen capture with it
so what i did is i evaluated the
cumulative distribution function at 1
which would be right
there
and i evaluate the cumulative
distribution function at -1
which is right there
and the difference between these two i
subtract this number
from this number and that tells me
essentially the probability that i'm
between those two numbers or another way
to think about it the area
the area right
here
and i really encourage you to play with
this and explore the excel formulas and
everything
this area right
right here between -1 and 1.
now one thing that shows up a lot is you
know what's the probability that you
land within the standard deviation of
and just so you know this graph the
central line right here this is the mean
and then these two lines i drew right
here these are one standard deviation
below and one standard deviation
above
the mean
and
some people think you know what's the
probability that i land within one
standard deviation of the mean well
that's easy to do what i can do is i'll
just click on this
and i could call this what's the
probability that i land between let's
see one standard deviation my the mean
is minus five one standard deviation
below the mean is minus fifteen
and one standard deviation above the
mean
is ten
plus minus five is five so that's
between five and fifteen
so sixty eight point three percent
that's actually always the case that you
have a sixty eight point three percent
probability of landing within one
standard deviation of the mean assuming
you have a normal distribution so once
again that number comes from
that represents the area under the curve
here
this area under the curve
and the way you
you get it is with the cumulative
distribution function let me go down
here
every time i move this i have to get rid
of the pen tool
so you go from you evaluate it at plus
five
which is right here
right this was one standard deviation
above the mean which that's a number
right around there looks like it's like
i don't know eighty something percent
maybe ninety percent roughly and then
you evaluate it at once deviation below
the mean which was minus 15.
and this one looks like i don't know
roughly
15 or so 15 16 maybe 17 let's say 18
percent
but the the big picture is when you
subtract this value
from this value
you get the probability that you land
between those two and that's because
this value tells the probability that
you're less than
so when you go to the cumulative
distribution function you get that right
there
that tells the probability that you are
let me get i
keep scrolling back and forth
that tells you that you're the so when
you look when you go to five
and you just go right
over here
this essentially tells you this area
under the curve the probability that
you're less than or equal to five
everything up there and then when you
evaluate it at minus 15 down here it
tells you the probability that you're
down
back here so when you subtract this
from the larger thing you're just left
with
what's under the curve right there
and just to understand this
the spreadsheet a little bit better just
because i really want you to play with
it and
move the you know see what happens when
you know if i make this distribution it
was my the mean was minus five now let
me make it five
it just shifted to the right
it just moved over to the right by five
right whoops i'll use the pen tool it
just moved over to the right by five
if i were to
if and if i were to try to make the
standard deviation smaller we'll see
that the whole thing just gets a little
bit tighter let's make it
six
and all of a sudden this looks a little
bit tighter curve we make it two it
becomes even tighter and just so you
know how i calculated everything and i
really want you to play with this and
play with the the formula and get an
intuitive feeling for this the
cumulative distribution function and
think a lot about how it relates to the
binomial distribution and i covered that
in the last video
this i just to plot this i just took
each of these points i went to plot the
points between minus 20
and 20 and i just incremented by one
right i just decided to increment by one
so this isn't it's not a continuous
curve it's actually just taking plotting
a point at each point and connecting it
with a line
then i did the distance between each of
those points and the mean
right so i just took let's say that you
know this the
minus 5 this is this distance so this
just tells you the point minus 20 is 25
less than the mean right that's all i
did there then i divided that by the
standard deviation and this is
this is the z-score the standard z-score
right so this tells me how many points
how many standard deviations is -20 away
from the mean it's 12 and a half
standard deviations below the mean
and then i use that and i just plugged
it into essentially this formula to
figure out the height of the function so
let's say at minus 20 the height is very
low at minus five well let's say at
minus
at minus two the height is a little bit
better the height is going to be some
place
it's going to be like you know
right there
and then
and so that gives me that value but then
to actually figure out the probability
of that
what i do is i calculate the the
cumulative distribution function
between well
this is the value that the probability
that you're less than that so you know
the area under the curve below that
which is very very small it's not zero i
know it looks like zero here but that's
only because i round it it's going to be
you know zero zero zero one it's gonna
be a really really small number there's
some probability that we even get like
minus a thousand another intuitive thing
that you really should have a sense for
is
you know what is the problem
the integral over this or the entire
area of the curve has to be one because
that takes into account all possible
circumstances and that should happen if
we put a suitably small number here and
a suitably large number here
there you go we get 100 although this
isn't 100 we would have to go from minus
infinity to plus infinity to really get
it's just rounding to 100 it's probably
you know 99.9999999
or something like that
and so you know just and so to actually
calculate this what i do is i take the
cumulative distribution function of this
point
and i subtract from that the cumulative
distribution function of that point and
that's where i got this hundred percent
from
anyway hopefully that'll give you uh a
good feel for the for the uh for the
normal distribution and you know i
really encourage you to play with the
spreadsheet and to even make a
spreadsheet like this yourself and in
future exercise we'll actually use this
uh type of a spreadsheet to as an input
into other models so if you know we're
doing a financial model and if we say
our revenue has a normal distribution
around some expected value what is the
distribution of our net income or or we
could think of a 100 other different
types of examples anyway see in the next
video